I can't talk about bro you used to do
hardcore drugs
what happened to you now you're all soft
and [ __ ] all right it used to be a
[ __ ] hardcore go drug gosh it didn't
go in my mouth son
[Music]
I'm Kevin Smith for first we least and
this is not once
[Music]
my guest today is a indie film legend
even sometimes not indie films just a
movie legend he's been playing the same
part for 25 years man he's like the
Kelsey Grammer of indie film he's a icon
American legend welcome to 2 not ones
Jason moves welcome Jason meters why are
you talking like that because we're on
because this is not once and we're on it
we're get to eat hot food on the
internet like me because that did you
ever see that better show but now
there's a show online okay where they
have famous people on and they eat hot
food and put it gets increasingly hotter
and they talk about like whatever
they're working on the stuff and so I
thought because Jay and Silent Bob
reboot is coming out yeah October 15th
and October 17th on screens everywhere
through fat and events or on the reboot
Roadshow tour with Jason and I actually
sitting down there and watching the
movie with the audience tickets at
reboot Roadshow calm I thought with a
new movie coming out that we'd be able
to go on to that show like other like
people who are promoting stuff and then
we get to eat some hot food and we get
interviewed and stuff like that but they
our publicist reached out to the other
show and they they said they weren't
interested so I said let's do our own
show and that's not once so I'm gonna
get er view you while we eat how to eat
food man now let's go on to round 1 a
nurse Auto Show round one of nook one
dammit
graphic how hot is this this is
basically we're at the junior level this
is a grade you know a sriracha this is
like what you get babies at Birth they
come out the womb they stick this in
their mouth because this is the weakest
of all the hot sauces so that's what
we're gonna begin with I've never seen
the show but I think they eat and then
they talk what's just hmm do you I
should point out from veggie grill so
it's not me
meatless oh but see I supposed to be
shuffled on yeah it's hot
I shouldn't swallow the way I did i pre
swallowed whoa and he hits the throat
and it's all hot now your charts give me
I didn't commit to a pulse wall but now
it's like linger in their [ __ ] but you
know what hair of the dog ooh level one
top for me so ESCO AB I'll break down
right now
yes shake his back in time to an early
story he does a live show Jay he's some
muses amusing stories where he stands up
there by himself
hey what about them don't up scene tell
stories tell us that one of the stories
that you tell when you're on stage so
when Kevin and I first met sort of met
we'd grew up in the same town were very
close to each other but I didn't know
him he is like hey there's the Johnsons
ass Mitch you know everybody's served
but you don't know that there's
literally straight onsens in the smooth
exactly and so I knew him I didn't know
him I've heard him talk about it before
saying hey there's that troublemaker he
got caught jerking off behind a pharmacy
he got caught putting peanut butter on
his [ __ ] and let it cat lick it off
never saw those things well yeah this
shit's making you sweat son how many I
can even think about the story my mouth
is on fire oh yeah I know yeah it's hot
Brown [ __ ] hot
this one's go to round two of knuckle on
man
demanda man right graphic them in a
minute I don't even know like legged
around to Bob Oh beyond insanity around
what was hard enough and that was the
layman things I feel you you're sweating
I'm stuck my mouth's on fire I'm glad we
didn't get on the show but we'd have to
eat that [ __ ] you're not kidding man if
we got on the real version of this show
like is that beat I'd be crying in front
of man I don't know sorry
[Music]
no fake well oh sorry are you serious
I'm gonna try to smear it over
that's hot oh my god that's hot whoa
right
why'd you do that no way yeah that was a
big dollar wow I got you against the
ropes let me ask you this how did you
meet your wife well Jordan Monsanto is a
producer of Jay and Silent Bob reboot
Jason Mewes is married to the producer
of JJ and saw Bob booboo they were
married long before that movie but after
the first book Jane saw Bob strike back
how did you meet your wife well well
well there's no how do people do this
from it's a very successful show some
people do is they really eat oh you
think I can't imagine it's part of level
2 and I swear I think it's level 1000
million all right speaking of level 1000
I bet George Bob Jordan
bro you used to do hardcore drugs what
happened to you now you're all soft and
[ __ ] all right it used to be a [ __ ]
hardcore drug gosh it didn't go in my
mouth son it went right who do all those
years ago I should have just grabbed you
a bit like uh Mary ah son of a [ __ ]
pour this [ __ ] in your throat you were a
better cop clean a sober that's true
it's true now give a [ __ ] I was trying
to put him in descending order
[ __ ] ah it's that hot yes his spittle
[ __ ] hi Jordan I met my buddy Andy
Milonakis invited me out to some club he
invited me to a club and I remember
being like I don't want to go out cuz at
that point I just got sober and I didn't
want to I didn't really go out much
because I was sober and I didn't really
hang out and stuff hard to watch
especially you're talking about my
ladylove
[ __ ] big old [ __ ] high round three
of luck one damn independent minute man
in the background graphic maneuver round
three I don't even know if they do that
on the real show I don't even know I
hear they do like it's a half an hour
show yeah probably with my our
conditions good thing I didn't write get
on I'm saying all sorts of reasons well
well I'm a cognitively reframing it yeah
cuz I want to be on the show but so much
so that I'm like here's our show not one
not one round three I say because we're
doing round three only I'll tell you
right now goes right to the big dog you
could do that I request no I think you
the ranch [ __ ] that I requested ranch
this [ __ ] so hot man but you should do
it I'm gonna tell you a man five he's
man I'm gonna wait I'll spell it am a
dick actor way to it cuz before we
really talk so I really think I should
wait to the lab well I'm gonna do mine
with ranch because do it gotta
neutralize the burn I to this little bit
here on the corner is a little tidbit
I'm gonna slice it off and eat it right
when you say that's what ranch takes
down almost I beat you rent you know
what I think we should do a show where
we put the like [ __ ] chicken right in
our mouth we like lady in the trap it
but we have the hot sauce and never
drops it first that's to go good idea
good idea and that is not knob first we
[ __ ] all right here we go man let's
[ __ ] watch you will see a man die
this is like faces of death 2019
is it hot do you feel it is it kicking
in do you need your milk which I call an
ambulance and started make my tongue
like I think you're uh you're a father
to a young child he's got a
four-year-old daughter you shouldn't be
[ __ ] around with hot food you got a
kid to care for I think the other one I
I wasn't prepared except that it was
number two right
but this you're like I put go ride most
ghosts and I put more on it and I like
took a bite like you said and I like my
whole mouth touched it where this when I
chewed a right side here and so a little
bit I gotta be honest with you when you
said my whole mouth touched if I go a
little just a little hard first time let
me show you something
do it yeah that's what they ought to do
on the show you know what I'm saying
just show go to God the other one this
one is show nuns not ones do it to you
closer that's hard
oh [ __ ] these were all his eyes but this
is ghost I mean now that we conquered it
I want you to tell that camera I want
you tell that camera I want you to tell
that camera what you promote go to Jim
uses twitch and watch me walk [ __ ] this
is a stop spinning
good lord the show never mind
not ones it should be called snot ones
cuz like iris I met my wife on the
streets is you judge is pretty Jay and
Silent Bob reboot is gonna be in
theaters nationwide October 15 October
17 details of Patton events calm or come
see the movie with me and Jay and we
won't make you do this I promise reboot
Roadshow calm tickets for that man
thanks from all of us here at first we
least thanks for hanging out and
watching not ones